cooking is about using your senses and
intuition you don't need measuring cuts
this is your measuring cup one cup two
cup
i'm a korean american i like it an
immigrant kid but the food that i cook
is american you know i was raised here
there are a lot of things that i won't
teach you in this class exact
measurements exact volume precise cuts i
really believe in wiggle room
i like to wiggle
we had this truck we had twitter and it
was an opportunity to just cook the food
that we wanted to cook we didn't know it
was going to start a revolution i told
you i'm not going to show you the kogi
taco but i'm actually showing you the
kogi taco
in this class i'm going to teach you how
to make my mother sauces kimchi panchan
the kimchi tuna milk carnitas mung bean
potato scallion pancakes
mmm
if you don't look like dexter by the
time you finish making kikchi you didn't
do it right a lot of times you'll see in
recipes use only the leaves discard the
stems erase all that [ __ ] from your
mind use the whole vegetable what's the
worst that could happen it's gonna taste
better
yeah
now this is what you came to master
class for look at this
growing up as a young kid here in los
angeles it was very tough monday through
friday for a lot of immigrant families
we were made fun of and bullied we had
to just do whatever we had to do to
survive but the weekends were for us the
weekends were when we used to go to the
park and everyone would bring coyote and
short ribs to the party
and i swear when you put this on the
grill you can't stop people from eating
it before it hits the table i want to
teach you a lot about instinct about
feel about seeing things hearing things
smelling things
to me that's really cooking you didn't
learn how to make a recipe you learned
how to cook it will live with you
forever i will live with you forever and
you'll never be able to get rid of me
i'm roy choi and this is master class
[Music]
um
[Music]
jordan